my son received death threats from this
man
no you didn't you didn't the guy's class
where he's teaching yes i didn't
cause a disruption i did cause it yeah i
would call it that
so this march i performed a show at smu
and this ut arlington professor of logic
posted a call to action demanding people
call the school
and get it cancelled due to me being a
quote alt-right neo-nazi
as evidence of my nazi views he posted
completely fabricated tweets
i immediately had my half asian lawyer
bill richman officially request a
retraction of the lie legal definition
of what i sent was a love note
a requesting a retraction and a
correction to a review
you reviewed it and your conclusion was
that statements attributing
genocide to someone fake fake there's
literally okay but but he didn't
this professor of logic just went on
continuing with the false claims
non-stop publicly to his students
including that i sent neo-nazis to his
house and that i personally made death
threats against him and his family
myself only when i called the campus
police to verify the veracity of the
claims hey detective lee this is steven
crowder um
as far as i can see there's no
offense there's you know nothing of that
nature okay so considering this teacher
of logic was teaching slander and libel
to his students to prevent anyone here
from making a living we alerted the ut
arlington dean refer you mr crowder to
either our university attorney
not only did the school do nothing they
went out of their way
to support professor now keep in mind
this professor has also publicly
protested and harassed
conservative students i'm fortunate
enough to have a platform but it's scary
to think that if this man does this
publicly how is he treating his own
conservative students behind closed
doors
i'm not a guy who wants to destroy a
man's life suing him for verifiable
repeated attempts at libel but at this
point
what choice did i have hi professor
i just wanted to clarify something here
for the record because i know you've
been
working at this school for a while and
actually posting online that i'm a
neo-nazi some
false libelous claim i'd like to know if
you could correct the record
i would like to say that uh when you uh
went to your show and you told someone
what happened last year was during
spring break of last year
yeah you're hijacking my idea yeah i
understand but
spring break of last
his followers what attacks did i post on
he started putting death threats to my
son
yes one said i threatened your son when
my son was receiving death threats by
the way for the record i would
never ever threaten violence i don't
believe in violence unlike some of the
calls you made online i would never
threaten anybody
right now i just want to make sure that
men and women my son received death
threats from this man
i sent death to your son you have to get
me fired this man's lawyer
when did i call death threats to your
son this man is
[Music]
what i really hope is that in the future
what you will do is stop putting death
threats against me and my friends
which death threats where you've also
put through what death when did i ever
threaten you
your students anyone here your son when
what proof do you have that's a big
claim how about your how about your
facebook post
right now it's written down when did i
threaten anybody with violence because i
actually advocate against it right now
please no violence
but i think it's wrong to lie so do you
admit that that's not why i admit when i
admit that i never said those things no
that's what you said
i said thank you to yourself this is the
guy teaching you
logic and how to deal with truth this is
important here's the thing
he's been invited he's been invited
that's okay he's been invited
for an open forum debate repeatedly and
has declined it
he has falsely libeled and slandered not
only but members of my team repeatedly
and he has told you his students
something that is not true
you said i made it first no you said
that you said that i said those things
you claim that these quotes came from
the daily stormer initially you're a
professor of lodging that came from me
you posted this on your facebook page
saying stephen crowder posted this does
this come from the dailies
i never say these things don't touch
that guy did i ever say these things
i've never issued a threat but you have
well you know what you know why because
it's how i make a living and truth
matters
you're in a class we're supposed to
learn about truth but what if i were to
spread a rumor that for example you were
having a relationship with you or you i
have no idea
to get you fired would that be okay as
long as i don't like you this is
something your followers have done
there's something your followers have
done so when did i threaten anybody guys
next class when did i threaten anybody
when have i ever issued a threat of
violence to anyone
let me you said that i issued a death
threat to your son
family it's not true
no you didn't you didn't we have the
screenshots you said i did it myself i
didn't see those threats i said that
thrust against myself what threats from
me period
any threats from me when have i ever
said anything to be called the neo-nazi
ever
give you one justification nice try to
trip little coward
when have i ever said anything anything
in support
of neo-nazi ideology these people are
disrupting my classroom i'm kind of
curious what the university can do about
it that's correct we did but you the
school has done nothing
can we show you if you could take one
moment to look at this i think if you
saw how horrifying it is
he said i threatened to kill his family
and his son
right here it says i've had enough of
you little gay cartoon boys
you degenerate fox are going in the oven
with the cut
and he said that i said these things and
you have someone who's in charge of
teaching truth
and critical thinking to your students
who is lying
to say that i threatened his son's life
well that's not free speech that's
liable
well come on the show and we'll talk
about it or at a neutral meeting place
now a neutral meeting place
we can discuss it at a neutral meeting
place i'm not discussing with people who
made threats against my son whose
followers made threats against my son
all right i need you out of my mind i've
never threatened your son
i never knew you had a son i honestly i
thought you were gay it's like i'm in
bizarro land of lies
hello officers how are you clarify who
you are oh okay
oh well thank you for the guys where he
speaks yes
i did cause it yeah i would call it that
to answer questions just
tell us
my mind and some of the locations sure
is night follows day after we filmed
this video we sat back and waited for
charles hermes to do what he does
lie again i'm fortunate to have a
platform
but keep this in mind if i don't have
this show if i'm someone like you
and this person makes these claims and
people believe it you don't have a job
you never work again your reputation is
ruined forever
but keep in mind as always on this
channel civil discourse
is always the first choice but if you
make threats
calls to violence or repeatedly abuse
your power to lie to your pupils and
refuse to admit the truth
i will find you i will expose you
and i will shame you america first love
the flow
yeah yeah i don't like hitler
hitler number one
wow
[Music]
please tell me you got that